[Music]
in today's tech savvy world it's all
around you an invisible world of
electromagnetic signals and radio waves
Wi-Fi or wireless fidelity is
responsible for over 60% of the planets
internet traffic it's seemingly
everywhere yet imperceptible to the
human eye but what if you could see it
what would Wi-Fi look like and what
would it do to you if you could see it
this is what if and here's what would
happen if Wi-Fi was visible your eyes
are pretty remarkable and I'm not just
saying that to be nice you can see
colors over an electromagnetic
wavelength anywhere from 410 nanometers
here you'll find violet to roughly 680
nanometers the home of red this is what
we call visible light also known as the
visible spectrum it's what humans can
view without the aid of any fancy tech
devices things like Wi-Fi are invisible
to the human eye but what if it wasn't
what would Wi-Fi look like there are
upwards of 4 billion people accessing
the Internet around the world that's a
lot of Wi-Fi signals if you can see them
you would be peeking into the unseen
world of electromagnetic fields Wi-Fi is
all about transmitting and receiving
data in the gigahertz range if you woke
up one day with the ability to see these
signals you would see frequencies up to
30 gigahertz wavelengths greater than 10
millimeters not so bad right
well it is speculated that Wi-Fi waves
or pulses are approximately 15
centimeters apart so imagine a
bombardment of colored bands taking over
your vision with everything that we have
in our homes that relies on Wi-Fi and
the ever-expanding availability of the
signal like citywide public Wi-Fi
networks the visual stimulation would be
too much so what would happen to you if
you started seeing Wi-Fi it would be
overwhelming to say the least prepare
yourself for the worst headache in the
history of headaches it would be
inescapable Wi-Fi routers or antennas
can be attached to almost anything
including trees buildings lampposts and
other structures
if you think that fleeing to the
wilderness would work a typical outdoor
router can reject its signal 300 feet
are more from its location all those
routers would be creating a circular
data field around them talk about being
surrounded there have also been claims
that just being exposed to
electromagnetic fields can cause
symptoms of anxiety depression nausea
and suicidal thoughts so imagine what
would happen if you could see them if
you could see these signals you'd
probably be looking for the deepest cave
you could find to hide in to escape from
the constant barrage of lights and
freakiness but could something like this
actually happen well technically we
could make this a reality but it's not
something that would ever occur
naturally it's easy to take a pair of
say infrared goggles off but if you were
stuck with this ability forever you'd be
crushed by the overwhelming amount of
visual input overall the idea of being
able to witness Wi-Fi in action sounds
like a really cool idea but we should
limit it to our technology not ourselves
thankfully our natural eyes aren't
capable of seeing this invisible world
and we should consider ourselves lucky
electromagnetic waves can have all sorts
of strange effects on us it's even
theorized that they're responsible for
what we know as ghosts makes you think
doesn't it now what if ghosts were real
well that's a story for another what if